the new valorant champions model has
officially been announced and while
they're very very pretty it's brought up
the conversation once again that skins
environment can be kind of pricey so
what's the deal are we paying too much
money for valerian skins
[Music]
hey everyone this video is brought to
you by our friends over at elgato they
sent me their ever so famous stream deck
that i've literally been using every
single day since i've gotten my hands on
it i use it for just chilling in vc with
my friends videos game streaming you
name it it's literally my new favorite
piece of hardware it's a huge thank you
and shout out to elgato the 2022
ballarat champions tournament is just
around the corner so you know what that
means optic and louder in the same group
like some star-crossed lovers
and also maybe more importantly new
skins if you haven't seen the news ride
games announced the newest champion skin
bundle saying quote the champion's 2022
collection contains the champion's 2022
phantom butterfly knife trophy card
buddy and spray from august 23rd to
september 21st 50 of the net proceeds
from the champions 2022 collection will
go to participating teams items won't
return to the store or night market dude
this phantom's already better than the
champions vandal because the champions
like doesn't make noises
wait
this thing's insane
what
i thought i don't just sound like the
normal phantom
this new phantom's actually insane chad
last year it was the vandal with the
word champions that also had a specific
sort of finisher except this year the
2022 phantom has a little more pizzazz
if you will also in my humble opinion it
just looks nicer also instead of a
butterfly knife it was a karambit in the
2021 collection last year's collection
had raised at one point over 7 million
dollars with 50 of the proceeds going to
participating teams like this years
these have never come back into the
market so if you never got around to
getting it tough luck these champions
bundles however are a little bit
different than the normal skin bundles
that come into your market in valorant
there are different tiers of skin
bundles they range from the least
expensive to the most expensive which
each tier getting progressively more
fancy so with the bundles depending on
when they came out you could be paying
anywhere from forty dollars to literally
over one hundred dollars and the best
part about bundles is they don't cover
every single gun in the game with some
of these skins specifically the more
expensive ones you actually have to
purchase currency to upgrade them for
vfx or finishers
so skins can be a pretty big investment
the other big part about ballerin skins
is that if you miss the release of the
bundle you have to wait until rng is in
your favor and it comes into your shop
your shop resets every 24 hours you only
have four slots there so you might be
waiting for a while real ones remember
when shazam finally got the ion sheriff
in his shop
[Applause]
no way
let's go oh my god
[Applause]
what the
it's riot creating false scarcity yes
absolutely but damn does it feel good
when you've been waiting forever and the
gun you finally want comes into your
shop
and you only have to pay like between
ten and
twenty dollars thirty dollars like other
games and valor you don't buy the skins
directly with your money you actually
have to buy currency in game and use
that currency to buy the skins for
example in league of legends the star
guardian 2022 passed with 1650 rp which
is over ten dollars but under 20
not great at math would be like 13 bucks
at most the star guardian bundle was
2650rp which by liz math would be 19
bucks at most looking at various luck
skins online they range from 520 to
3250rp but these are drastically
different price points for different
cosmetics in some other games like world
of warcraft you do spend money directly
for cosmetics like a pet rather than
purchasing the currency to buy it so
compared to valerian skins there really
isn't that much of a difference the only
thing i think you really could say is
that in valor you have to dump a bit
more money to upgrade your skins for
like finishers visual effects etc i
asked you guys on twitter if you had any
buyer's remorse for skins in valerian
and y'all had a lot to say some of you
don't regret buying skins at all despite
the amount you pay for them while others
really do regret the purchases they have
made some of you have no purchases to
regret it all to which i say good for
you i promised fox i read his tweet in a
dramatic way so here goes nothing yes
while i'm buying the credits pain floods
my heart and i make up scenarios where
i'm homeless and need that extra fifty
dollars but then i spin the knife around
and i feel better
overall valorant is a free-to-play game
that riot has to make money from somehow
and one way they do that is via really
really cool skins not every skin
collection is going to have cool effects
or transitions much sinead shots chagrin
but it's a really cool way to show up
your personal style within the game as
much as fox was making a joke in his
tweet he is hitting on the point that we
purchase the skins because they make us
happy we literally buy them because we
like what we see and how we feel with it
etc however if you're a girl like me who
is very very strict about her budgie
because she is moving out on her own
tomorrow and those fifty dollars on
skins could be groceries it's hard to
justify buying skins side note house
party at my new place
anyways begins i remember when the zed
bundle came out and it was like a
hundred dollars for the entire thing
making it one of the most expensive
bundles to be in the game bundles have
continued to be rather expensive and
those are just the base skins those are
not counting the upgrades this point was
drifting home when i looked up writing
this piece how much money it actually
spent on valorem skins
and it was twenty dollars shy of one
thousand dollars
mom if you're watching this i'm blind
everyone else
i'm not lying everyone's financial
situation is different but is riot
asking too much money for cosmetics that
offer no in-game advantage in my opinion
no you don't have to buy skins in this
game you can still be match mvp and have
no skins is the game less fun
maybe but between you and me the default
vandals loki aimbot i play gentian
impact where your success in the game is
literally made easier by spending money
this is a completely different beast
gentian impact is predatory gambling
valerian is not that personally i think
you're going to go after valorent for
what they charge you better be equitable
and go after every single game that does
the same thing for now i will personally
enjoy the skins i pick up off the ground
because i am not comfortable spending
any more money on the game but if it's a
smart financial decision for you and it
makes you happy go for it say lovey i am
not going to yuck someone else's young
the riot buddy is a free cosmetic that's
like the most exclusive one you know
what i mean because you have to like
know someone who knows someone who knows
someone who knows someone or like
impress a riot dev on twitter
imagine they sold riot buddies oh god
that would go for so much money
oh
wait that's
[Music]